so the first thing we're going to want
to do is download and run our sample
application now I don't actually know
where the zip file is going to be but
hopefully by the time this video gets
posted will know and so thanks to the
magic of YouTube annotations and
post-processing and stuff I'm going to
put it up on screen right now okay so I
want you to follow that link hopefully
there will be a zip file there that you
can download and by the time you unzip
it you should get something that looks a
little like this it's a basic Xcode
project let's open it up and take a look
at what we've got here now the first
thing I'm going to do before I even run
it is change my bundle identifier from
combat example to well in my case com
google you should change this to
something that's more appropriate for
your company I do find that if you
change the bundle identifier after
you've already run it once you end up
with two copies of the game on the
simulator and sometimes it gets confused
so I like to change it first before I
even run it once that's done we can run
it and check out our game and we are
presented with a fantastic main menu
where I get to pick from an easy medium
and hard difficulty level for the guests
my number game I'm going to pick an easy
game here and I get to guess a number
between 1 and 100 so I'm going to start
by guessing 50 and it's higher than 50
you'll notice that as it tells me the
value is higher or lower than what a
guest the min and Max values here they
tell me what the minimum and maximum
possible values could be for our mystery
number so let's seal guess 85 it's
higher than 85 how about 90 to iron the
92 Wow okay all right 95 got it in five
guesses and now it's asking me if I want
to play again and I don't think I well
because that wasn't really all that much
fun so we're going to stop this and
let's get a quick overview of this
application I'm not going to spend a lot
of time on this partly because it's
pretty basic but also because
there's a very good chance you are a
better objective-c programmer than I am
so if you find that you're doing
something different than the way I'm
doing it don't assume that my way is
necessarily more proper or more correct
than what you're doing there's a very
good chance that you're doing the right
thing and I'm not and if so feel free to
leave some suggestions in the comments
I'll read those just you know don't be a
jerk about it so first thing we're going
to do let's take a look at the app
delegate well we've got here is pretty
basic we're creating an intro view
controller and we're creating a
navigation controller and then we're
simply taking our intro view controller
and making that the the root of our
navigation controller we display that on
the screen and we're ready to go let's
take a look at our interview controller
we can see here in the nib we've got
three buttons easy medium and hard for
playing on those different difficulty
levels if we look at our dot M file
basically the three buttons here I'll
call start game with difficulty with a
different difficulty level I'll start
game with difficulty does is it creates
a game view controller sets the game
difficulty and then pushes that to the
top of our navigation controller if
you're wondering where these difficulty
levels are coming from that's coming
from our enemies h-file where we define
the difficulty level as well as a reply
enum that simply tells the player
whether the guess was too high to low or
they got it just right and they went so
let's take a look at our game model next
in our dot H file you'll see we have a
number of properties here game max is
the maximum possible value for any game
so in a game where I'm guessing between
one and a thousand game X will always be
a thousand player Minh and player max
are the minimum and maximum values based
on the players guesses so far so you'll
saw you saw when I guess 50 didn't told
me it was too low and that my min and
Max were 51 and 100 that's what player
min and player max are numb guess this
is the number of guesses that I've made
so far max length is the maximum number
of digits that are possible in my answer
and that's based on the game max value
and then we have two public methods new
game with level which simply starts a
new game with a particular difficulty
level and player guest takes a guess
from the player and returns one of those
reply enums that says too high to low or
you win
if we look at the game model we can see
most of these methods new game with
level will define the game max based on
the difficulty level it will generate a
secret number reset the player min and
player max reset number of guesses 20
and determine the max length again based
on the number of digits in game max
player guest increments the number of
guesses it will adjust the player min
and player max values as appropriate
depending on what a guest and will
return to high to low or you've won you
know so now let's take a look at the
game view controller this is probably
where most of the interesting game logic
is if you look at the nib we've got some
basic labels a text field I guess button
minimax labels a response label and to
play again button if we look at the dot
H file we really only have one property
here and that's the game difficulty
you'll recall that was set by the intro
view controller when we start a new game
and finally in our dot M file let's go
to the top here we have a number of
properties to represent all of the UI
elements on screen as well as a game
model and a boolean to determine whether
the game was over or not start game
calls a new game with level on our game
model and resets a number of on-screen
elements at that point it updates the
interface updates the min/max labels and
basically just preps the screen for a
new game update min max labels just
updates those labels based on what we
got from the model update interface
based on game over shows or hides
various buttons depending on whether the
game is over or not play game button was
pressed starts a new game guests button
was pressed is probably where most of
the interesting logic is in our game we
take the integer value from the players
guess and will pass that to our game
model through the public method player
guest and then based on the response we
either adjust some of the interface
elements on screen or if the player
guessed right then we say hey games over
and we update our interface this method
here text field should change characters
in range replacement string all this
really does is it make sure I can't
enter more digits in the
xfield then are appropriate for this
game so if I'm guessing a number between
1 and 100 this will stop me from
entering more than three digits touches
began with event this really just make
sure I hide the keyboard if I start
clicking on other elements on screen and
viewdidload sets up our game model sets
our text field delegate to self so that
this text field should change characters
and range method gets called so that's
about all there is to this application
feel free to try it out for yourself for
a little while feel free to experiment
look at what it all does and when you're
all done having fun with this game which
should take all of about 30 seconds
let's think about how we would start
adding some game services to this
application and the very first thing
we'll want to do is sign the user in and
so we'll start tackling that in the next
lesson
haha
ha